مارك زوكربيرج قادم
لحصة Twitter من سوق وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، حيث تقوم
شركة meta بإطلاق تطبيق
للتنافس معه ، يطلق عليه اسم المواضيع إذا
لم تكن قد سمعت بعد ، يأتي الإطلاق
وسط المزيد من التغييرات المثيرة للجدل على
Twitter.
التغريدات التي يمكن للمستخدمين رؤيتها في يوم واحد ،
يختلف المبلغ ، ولست متأكدًا تمامًا من السبب
اعتمادًا على ما إذا كنت قد دفعت للتحقق من
التحقق ، يقول المسك أيضًا أن الأشخاص
لن يتمكنوا من رؤية أي تغريدات ما لم
تقم بتسجيل الدخول على قناة CNN آنا ستيوارت يمكنني ذلك
أؤكد أنك كنت تتابع كل
هذا وسوف تشرح لي
الآن لأنني أريد أن أعرف آنا ، كما تعلم ، هل
ستحصل هذه النسخة الوصفية الجديدة من Twitter ، هل
تعتقد أن زوكربيرج لديه فرصة هنا
للدخول إلى هذا السوق
جيدًا ، هناك نوعان ضخمان  الفوائد هنا
ودعنا لا ننسى أن هناك
الكثير من منافسي Twitter لدينا
اجتماعية حقيقية ، فهناك Blue Sky كان هناك
عدد قليل ولكن فائدة
Instagram إطلاق سلاسل التطبيق الجديدة هذه
هي أنه يحتوي بالفعل على قاعدة مستخدمين ضخمة
أكثر  2 مليار مستخدم نشط شهريًا على
Instagram حتى يتمكن من الاستفادة من ذلك بالإضافة إلى أنه
ليس توقيتًا رائعًا لتويتر ، فهو
يدفع أيضًا عمليات التشغيل في metas favour
هنا حقًا هذا التحول
المستمر تحت إشراف Elon Musk قد يقول البعض
أنه لن يسير على ما يرام.  يسعد جميع المستخدمين
بإزالة علامات التجزئة الزرقاء الخاصة بهم ، فقد
ذكرت بعض المشكلات المتعلقة بعدد
التغريدات التي يمكنك رؤيتها كانت هناك
انقطاعات خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ، حيث تمت
إعادة الأشخاص الذين تم حظرهم
من النظام الأساسي بسبب الكلام الذي يحض على الكراهية والمعلومات
الخاطئة ، سواء من حيث
التوقيت وحقيقة أن هذا
عملاق وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لديه قاعدة مستخدمين ضخمة ،
يبدو جيدًا جدًا بالنسبة للمعادن
في الوقت الحالي ،
لذا سأتركه هناك في الوقت الحالي ،
وسنعقد الاجتماع على الرغم من أننا
سنذهب  احصل على هذا سوف
يتداول ، ستكون قصة
الأسبوع التي لن تنشرها يوم الخميس ،
وسألتقي هناك آنا
ستيوارت ، شكرًا لك على هذا الأمر بالنسبة لنا
الآن ، من المتوقع أن تصل سلاسل التذكير إلى
متاجر التطبيقات يوم الخميس  كنا
نتحدث فقط مع آنا
متحدون آخرون مثل Mastodon لقد حاولت
وفشلت في التغلب على Twitter ولكن الاضطراب
تحت قيادة Elon Musk قد يكون كما كانت
تقول Anna ، فقد خلقت فرصة مثالية
للدخول في Blue Sky
قال منافس آخر إنه شهد
ارتفاعًا قياسيًا في حركة المرور  في كلماته بعد أن
حدد Twitter عدد المنشورات التي يمكن للمستخدمين
قراءتها يوميًا الآن ، حيث يمكن
مزامنة المواضيع مع Instagram والتي ستكون
مشكلة كبيرة أخرى هنا مما يتيح لها الوصول
للحصول على هذا أكثر من مليار
مستخدم نشط Vivian Schiller هي
العالمية السابقة.  رئيس الأخبار في Twitter وليس هناك
شخص أفضل للتحدث إليه ، يرجى اللعب
بهذا الأمر بالنسبة لنا لأنك تعرف ما
أتساءل عما إذا كنت تعتقد أن
مفتاح هذا أن يصبح قابلاً للتطبيق
كبديل لتويتر
هو مستخدميه الأكثر شعبية ، أليس كذلك؟
اجعل كيم كارداشيان تنتقل إلى المواضيع ، هل
لديك باراك أوباما نجوم الروك
قادة العالم هو أن بداية النهاية
لتويتر ،
يمكنك التأكد من أن المديرين التنفيذيين في
ميتا يعملون مع جميع
جهات الاتصال الخاصة بهم ، وخاصة أولئك الذين
يستخدمون Instagram بكثافة والتي مثل  الذي
ذكرته هو مظهر تطبيق شائع جدًا ،
فأنت تعلم أن Twitter التقط
البرق حقًا في زجاجة على مدار
السنوات العشر الماضية آه أو أكثر
حتى
استحوذت um Elon Musk على الأمر
ودمرت الكثير مما أحبه الناس
في Twitter واستمر في ذلك  حتى
يومنا هذا ، كما تحدثت بينما
تحدث مراسلك عن عطلة نهاية الأسبوع الماضية ، مما يحد من
عدد التغريدات التي يمكن للأشخاص رؤيتها ، وهو
تكتيك غريب جدًا لنوع ما يشبه
القول بأنك تعرف
CNN تقول إننا سنحد من عدد
العروض التي يمكنك  شاهد
أم أنه ليس منطقيًا حقًا
وفقًا لنموذج العمل
الذي قال أنه من المحتمل أن يكون لـ uh meta
فرصة أكبر من أي من
المتنافسين بما في ذلك كما ذكرت
Blue Sky Mastodon ،
فهناك زوجان آخران مثل
um post dot news لا شيء من  لقد
تمكنوا حقًا من الاستيلاء على عباءة ، لكن من
الممكن أن ينجح هذا جيدًا وسنرى
بالتأكيد وسنرى ذلك
ومثيرًا للاهتمام ، أنت تعلم أن Verge
ذكرت أنك تعرف أن التنفيذيين في
بيتا استمروا في إخبارك بأنك تعلم أنهم
كانوا كذلك  أنهم هم أنفسهم كانوا
يسمعون من شخصيات عامة منشئي المحتوى
أنهم كانوا مهتمين بامتلاك
منصة تم اقتباسها بشكل سليم ،
أعني أن هذا تم نقله ذهابًا وإيابًا على Twitter
مع Elon Musk و Meadow ، لكنك تعرف
meta Facebook ، لقد كان ملحميًا بشكل صحيح ، لقد تم
تأريخ مدى الضرر  لقد
كان إرثهم لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
قد يفوز بالمستخدمين الجدد من خلال
الوعد وتقديم
الاعتدال فعليًا وفقًا لمعايير أفضل ،
نعم أعني أنه من الصعب نوعًا ما أن
يكون أي منهما صادقًا ولكني
أعتقد أن meta لديها فرصة
أولاً  كل ما تعرفه هو أن meta لديها
الكثير من المشاكل وهي عبارة عن
محادثة ليوم آخر ولكنها
تعمل بشكل سليم وفعّال للغاية وأنت
تعلم أن قاعدة مستخدمي Instagram
هائلة وبالنظر إلى مدى تقلب
تويتر في الوقت الحالي لن يكون الأمر بهذه
الصعوبة  لن يتطلب الأمر الكثير ليكون
تحسينًا كبيرًا ولتوفير هذا النوع من
الخبرة التي تقول إنك تعلم أن Instagram
هو مظهر مختلف بشكل لا يصدق
عن Twitter
أو Instagram هو مكان ننشر فيه
صور أطفالنا وإجازاتنا
وآخرها
الوجبات التي قمنا بطهيها وهي
مختلفة ، نوعًا ما
تعرفه نوعًا ما من مكان مريح حيث
يشارك الأشخاص ربما صورًا مثالية بشكل مفرط
Twitter هو مكان يتحدث فيه الناس
عن قضايا صعبة
أم رؤساء الدول أه استخدم Twitter
للإعلان  يتجادل عمالقة الأعمال
حول الأشياء التي كانت نوعاً ما واحدة
من أفراح تويتر الرائعة
بالتأكيد كان هناك الكثير من المشاكل
ولكن هل تعلم ما هي مجرد
تجربة مختلفة تمامًا عن Instagram ، لذا
فأنا لست متأكدًا تمامًا من كيفية القيام بذلك  ستترجم
Vivian ، لم يتبق لي سوى 30 ثانية ، لكن هل من
المحتمل أن تكون هذه نهاية
Twitter ، أعني أنه لم يكن يكسب
الكثير من المال على أي حال أو أن أي أموال يمكن أن
تكون الموت حقًا الآن لأننا سنحقق ذلك.
انظر ، أعني إذا عكسوا
ذلك ، فأنت تعلم أنه لم يمت بعد
على الرغم من كل العثرات ، لذا أه وإذا
عكسوا الحد من المعدل ،
فيمكن أن يعيشوا لرؤية يوم آخر